hey everyone and welcome to series and
Thrones the place where you can cry and
scream about everything that happened in
the Battle of Winterfell
also known as episode 803 of Game of
Thrones I'm Liana Galera from
Entertainment Tonight and I'm Mike
Gousha from GameSpot before we get
started of course you shouldn't be here
until you have watched the episode
because we are getting into all the
spoilers spoilers spoiler alert
we're gonna keep telling you this every
week just like we're gonna keep telling
you about the fact that we want to know
your thoughts about what the hell went
down in last night's episode the long
night we're already starting to getting
so many comments Malik and Emma we see
you yes I start sending us your comments
about Aria's big moment and whatever
else you want to talk about plus we've
got an exclusive round of interviews
with the Game of Thrones actors who
perished in this episode spilling
behind-the-scenes secrets about what it
was like to film their final scenes in
the Battle of Winterfell
but first real quick Mike what did you
think of this episode I was I was kind
of lukewarm too positive on the last two
episodes because it was all building to
this but I am so incredibly disappointed
with this episode and I know that some
people liked it and I just I didn't like
deep in my bones I'm disappointed this
episode was written by David and Dan you
know the showrunners of the entire show
and to me it feels like they have missed
the point of the whole series like the
the running theme for me throughout the
books throughout the show has always
been that the battle for the throne
doesn't actually matter it's this petty
squabble between people who don't see
the bigger picture the apocalypse is
coming and everybody's blind to the
right they're ignoring it it's global
warming and the the Starks and the
Lannisters are Democrats and Republicans
at and they're ignoring what actually
matters and last night arias solved the
apocalypse and that's it's just over it
it amounted to nothing and now we have
three episodes left and they're just
back to their petty squabbles
I just everyone in the episode acted so
dumb they won by dumb luck the showed
Nord all the groundwork all the clues in
the foreshadowing that's been building
up for years and and for what it was
like a straightforward battle with a big
stupid bad guy no payoff no
and no actual well-earned twists how you
doing I get like I'm really I'm
obviously upset what did you think okay
so remember how last week it took me
three times of viewing the episode like
it I last night I was thinking is she
gonna watch this episode three times no
I watched it twice but it's the opposite
effect the more I watched this episode
the more I think about this episode the
more upset I am when I was watching it
it was heart pounding and enthralling
and I couldn't believe what was
happening and all these twists and all
the mini cliffhangers they were leaving
us on we're amazing and then when the
big Aria moment happened I was like oh
my god I mean it was shocking it was
shocking and then afterwards I was just
like why did they do that there were
some amazing things the dragon battle
yes gorgeous yeah there were a lot of
the parts that we could see revealed
yeah the parts of the episode that were
well lit we're beautiful but let's
continue this conversation because let's
kick things off with the biggest
question of every Game of Thrones
episode which is who died who died a lot
of ugly answer this one yeah we finally
have something to talk about we have a
lot to talk about to talk about kick it
off with our first death yeah who
matters sorry tooth Rocky kicking us off
with Edison we'll talk about that with
Edison II died dollars-- ed is gone I
feel like that was kind of a cheap one
to start with because he's very much
like a see to your character I agree at
best and I think that was a kind of
disappointing running theme throughout
the episode is that really only until
the very end only B and C tier died like
did you care about it no but and
especially because like I'm sorry like
in my opinion like I know Sam's a great
guy he should have not been on the
battlefield and as soon as Edie saved
him and then I was like oh he saved Sam
he's about to die like sure yeah as soon
as it happened it's just like oh boy
you're dead know where you're gonna die
and that's it I mean okay hang on though
yes Lyanna Mormont me Anna Mormont oh
man for such a pint-sized girl to get
such a big screen death was so exciting
she had the best death in the whole
episode zombie giant let's talk about
that let's break it down we have the
scene right now she
comes in little guns a-blazing with her
little spear well she gets knocked away
as you think she's in there I thought
she was dead right away I was like
there's no way that that's how they
would do her it's very it's very Book
Game of Thrones look at our charging at
the Giant he picks her up he's crushing
her to death and at the last second she
gets in the final kill chunk and I
thought it was just absolutely amazing
it was really sad though to see that
giant again because I was really sad too
you died the first time around but do
you think that's one one yes I do I
think they would have burned one one
after the Battle of the bastards but
I've seen people saying that that's one
way yeah I don't think it is I don't
know but it's up for debate it was very
sad moving on to beric Dondarrion how do
we feel about barrack dying it's kind of
severing the ties with the Lord of Light
I like barrack better in the books he's
like he's more of a Robin Hood figure
like that yeah he's like leads this band
of sort of like lawful outlaws and in
the show he's kind of just like a Lord
of Light fanatic like in the I thought
he's very telling in the last episode
when he comes up to the hound and re and
they're like please don't start watching
like we don't want to hear it so I felt
very little for his death and then on
top of that like the fact that his
entire purpose according like Melisandre
said it like the reason the Lord of
Light brought him back so many times is
so he could save Arya and I thought that
was kind of cheap because Arya has never
needed saving before like she is good
right yeah and even if she needed to be
saved the Hound is there anyway Oh was
he there was he there cuz I'm pretty
sure he was having a panic attack the
entire episode no no he's got with any
caught up Avengers we're gonna pause
before we continue on because we've
gotten so many great fan comments malik
says my favorite moment was when Lyanna
Mormont struck the dragonglass dagger
into the giant sigh that was pretty
badass yeah it was one of my favorite
moments
yeah for sure and then interest Aaron
said the fact that Sam is still alive is
beyond me it's it's I I definitely need
to complain about this a little bit
because the episode constantly cut back
to like Brienne Sam Jamie and pod like
the same a handful of characters just in
the yard at Winterfell dive in more
danger the entire episode at one point
Sam was lying on the ground just crying
with a pile of zombies on top of him and
it was like the shot
it was the shots that they kept falling
back on yeah there was no movement there
was no progression nothing ever changed
in their situation and there were no
snakes none of them died yeah I don't
understand like to me that's it's it was
just badly ya can see but you know who
did die yeah Chuck - I'm on Jorah
Mormont so we got we got a comment that
I saw yeah from Emma and I I'm sad we
lost Jorah and Lyanna but I'm glad they
both went out the way they did both
deaths were very true to their
characters agree I fully agree I mean
it's house Mormont done my house Marwan
is done it seems like I'm really sad I
don't know if the top my head they must
have there must be like a baby somewhere
who can take command
I mean if Leanna was the one who is
leading in she was yeah and George aura
told her last episode you know you're
the future of our houses like do you
think I don't know that and yet and yet
there she was in the thick of battle
yeah do you think it was interesting I'm
personally glad that Jorah did not have
final words to Danny I feel like
anything that he would have said would
have come off cheesy almost yeah I'm
happy that it looked like he was gonna
say something and then he didn't I think
the show gets criticized rightfully a
lot of the time for having kind of
falling back on cheesy one-liners yeah I
think jours actions spoke louder than
his his words in this case and I thought
he had a very good death it also kind of
made me think back to the episode when
back in Mereen when everyone was coming
for Danny and it reminded me of the fact
that Danny without her dragons has no
combat she has never had to fight how
did you credits she picked up that sword
yeah and she started swinging it but
yeah after I sure had not been there I
mean there were there were moments when
I thought Danny was gonna die yeah I
thought that she was fair game for this
episode yes
she's she's had this arc and in true
Game of Thrones fashion it would be a
good place to cut her short yeah you
know to leave us wanting Jorah was a
good man you know who else is a good man
accorded a bridge oh yes the reason sure
that that's true according to bran Theon
Greyjoy is a good man but I think what
it was is that brand saw that
yawns death was coming and he was like
so you're about to die
I don't really fully believe this fig
you're a good man man I don't understand
why wife and brand like Brandon knows
what's about to happen
Zuma bleep does he I mean like why send
Theon to yes to his death like I mean go
ahead thanks for the help he's like grab
your little spear and look at him charge
there you go what a terrible plan my
favorite part is that the night king
just kind of died it's so easy I mean
you know what I was really hoping for
here what there he goes
yep I was really hoping for like the
great joy words right what his dead may
never die for that easy yeah as he's
running that would be actually really
pretty on to have a moment where he gets
up but I don't know he they've
established like he's home he's a stark
but it would have been weird had he been
gone to his character arc was complete
for sure but I just I wanted it's one of
the many things that I wanted to matter
yeah just a wound up not well in random
commented and said Theon's death scene
was incredible and beautiful and sad he
dies thinking they've lost oh that's a
great really good I ran I'm the fact
that he charged and really thought like
alright I'm gonna give it my all were at
the bitter end yeah he goes out a hero
and I kept thinking of his conversations
that he's had with with I think with
Yara and definitely with John yeah over
the seasons about he has never been
confident in his identity's a Greyjoy or
is he a stark and brands words to him
cemented your home yeah and that doesn't
mean you're a star no it means that
you're home
ready you can die home you can die
peacefully yeah yeah he went out another
peaceful death
well Sondre that woman let's talk about
this I don't understand what the point
of her was she came back to life the
sword I'm gonna I'm gonna ran more about
this later but it seemed like most of
everything she did just wound up not
mattering at all it mattered in the in
the fact that apparently this was her
final battle this is the moment that the
Lord of Light led her to when she saw
the battle in the snow it wasn't with
Stannis it was this mole
at Winterfell she came in she helped
what she could real clutch moment though
when she lit the trenches because nobody
else can get to them thank you for
making it so we could see the episode oh
yeah I saw this Mel is the real hero of
the episode yeah because she made it so
that we could see what was happening
Lumis sorry so I guess I guess I guess
that was her point I I thought I thought
she died well it was nice to be reminded
that she's like 500 years old yeah or
whatever for Davos to finally witness
that I don't know what that means I
don't know if it'll ever be brought up
again he already knows that she's got
magical powers he was there for the
smoke verse that's true one of the
things that I love so much is that as
she was walking out there it just really
reminded me of the the power of a good
piece of jewelry can you really just
make a big difference in a woman's life
yeah I like it seems very significant
that the the light went out it was kind
of a yeah it was a beautiful moment I
agree um but let's move on from the red
woman's death and finally talk about the
death of the night came he died we have
so much to talk about so I want to move
on into our next section which is
talking about the biggest moments of the
night with Om ggot and we need to talk
about the fact that Arya killed the
night king thoughts I'm still processing
this she so Arya won the Battle of
Winterfell and I think that to devian
David's credit did I see it coming no
they did a really great job with the
bait-and-switch of all the mini
cliffhanger scenes the fact that I was
worried about Jon with the zombie dragon
I was worried about like how they were
gonna get to brand I had no idea what
was going on then Arya just jumps out of
nowhere I mean to me Arya being the one
yeah who does it is this is it it's
actually like a better oh yeah we got
our little hint of it yeah as she was
running by and then she comes in with
the cat's paw dagger she was their
trampoline behind him I mean she's she's
sprightly like independent of the way
that they actually did which was cool
that was fortunate when she had when she
had her battle with Brienne yes she was
very shocked that was really great
I already killing the night are you like
quietly walking up to the night King and
just stabbing him in the middle of the
battle is a running joke in the game of
Thrones fan community do you like yes
all of the speculation what if it all
comes to nothing and Arya just quietly
walks up and stabs him good like you
know a faceless man yeah and they went
with that and I can't believe it like
what do you think okay well here's my
one thing and we were gonna be talking
about this later so let's queue up the
scene of creating the white Walker for
the very first time thank you so much
for following along with us prompter so
basically my real issue with this is
that DB and David said in the behind the
scenes of the episode that Arya needed
to strike the night king in the exact
same spot in his chest where they put
the Dragons the the Dragons glass I
thought he was I thought they were
saying in the exact spot that it
happened originally exactly gods words
exactly she hit him in the leg no I
thought she hit him in the socket of her
thing but the leg I interpreted is that
she needed to put in the exact same spot
where his dragon glasses and I thought
that that was wildly unbelievable yeah I
mean she I know they've like said like
this is where it is I mean they said in
the in the like post episode feature up
where they talk about the making of
inside the episode yeah they said that
they have known that it would be Arya
for three years which I do think I don't
know if they think that's a good thing
but this series has been going for like
23 years so this it feels like something
that they just came up with and they
said they essentially did it because we
wouldn't be thinking of Arya in that
moment so basically they just wanted it
to be unexpected but for me that's not
inherently good like it's unexpected
because it doesn't build on the
foreshadowing the clues yeah all the
groundwork that's been laid over the
course of the entire series just gets
thrown away in our age of steps it
almost like as predictable as it would
have been if John had been the one to
kill him it almost felt like this wasn't
arias battle when did I ever express
that she cared about this at all well
like she she cares from fighting for her
family and she's like the super badass
now but honestly it just felt like it
felt disingenuous that she was the one
to kill him
you guys tell me what you think uh let's
see Augustus said they gave the night
King the snoke treatment I think yeah
you think he's the final boss yeah and
now it's Cersei I mean I mean Patrick
said the night King needed to go boring
character agreed that's fair but what I
wanted is for them to make the night
King not boring yeah and they had so
many opportunities when we finally
started to learn more about the night
king with brands visions it felt like
you know we learned about how the White
Walkers are created so it felt like they
were finally opening up to the backstory
and then this whole season I've been
waiting for the moment is it going to be
when bran has that conversation with
Tyrion that we never saw is it going to
be when the night King walks up to brand
are they finally going to have a
dialogue have a conversation where we
learn what the White Walkers want what
are they doing apparently they just
wanted to kill brand because he knows
everything just to kill everyone it's so
boring it's such it's such like a he's
just a big boring bad guy and there's
nothing more to it let's switch out
something that's equally as frustrating
which is the fact that the night is dark
like really dark not see anything in
this episode I was watching from a
computer because I was working last
night yes it was dark but like I was
watching on a big TV and I couldn't see
me we really we had to we were like
putzing with the TV settings trying to
turn the brightness all the way up in
the middle of the episode yeah I saw a
lot of jokes on Twitter that like the
real enemy tonight is HBO's digital
compression yeah you just I couldn't
like they hyped up this battle so much
and for at least half of the episode I
could not read the action what's
happening yeah what are the state look
at it right now like like there's
Brienne cuz she's right there and then
there's Jamie and grey worm it's hard to
shoot a battle at night I got that and
I'd love that their response was it's
realistic it's like you the sugar
dragons and direwolves oh we're gonna
get to that in a little bit
do you know what else would be realistic
yeah if they like had a bunch of fires
lit they had two tiny bonfires out in
front of Winterfell just if you have
more fire to fight the enemies that are
civically weak to fire then we would be
able to see two birds one so we had fire
with the Dothraki that it burned out
real quick right oh my god that was sad
I'm still gonna rant about that another
letdown was the fact that the Crypt the
Crypt is the safest place in Winterfell
the Crypt is the safest place and water
fell there was so much for shadowing
that it was so obvious yes and then it
didn't like the real twist is that it
didn't matter no one important died no
interesting Gilly didn't die was
baffling to me but one of the things
that you and I were talking about he
wanted things that you and I were hoping
would happen was the fact that someone
that we knew from the stark family would
come back and would scare the bejeezus I
don't know how they I don't know how
they did the [ __ ] yeah without having at
least Rickon riggan died too you know
the end of season six yeah I think he's
a fresh corpse specifically John had him
buried in the crypts he would be up at
the top where all the people are and he
is buried with a sword and he it just
never mattered yeah not it this episode
felt self-contained as if as if all of
the things that have happened over the
past seven seasons before this just
didn't matter as if the show doesn't
trust us to remember these things I
almost wish it had ended on a
cliffhanger the fact that it wrapped up
so neatly I'm kind of like I don't trust
it yeah that felt like it should have
been the climax of the entire series
exactly eyes back to now before we fully
jump into all of our theories and
comments we've got an exclusive
interview with a handful of your
favorite game of Thrones stars talking
about their final scenes and what it was
like to actually film the Battle of
Winterfell spoiler alert is cold yeah
take a look
I think Jorah probably more than most
has teetered on the edge of his own
demise
[Music]
so what was your reaction when you read
your script for your final episode what
was your initial reaction mmm just that
the guys that nailed it you know I think
throughout really all the episodes
yeah just wonderful writing it kind of
you know it's such a hard thing to pull
off I think you know the expectations
are so high and yeah I think they just
managed all the storylines incredibly
well and you know it's full of the
throws mix of the unexpected and the
dramatic and you know massive set pieces
and yeah extraordinary happenings and
things beyond our care it's kind of more
the same but bigger better
[Music]
I was really happy yeah I was really
happy pleased
[Music]
was there ever a point with in Game of
Thrones that you thought that you're
gonna get axed earlier just about the
entire yeah all seasons throughout the
entire thing yeah yes I did get a phone
call at one points from the producers
and they said we want to have a dinner
with you and I was like and that at that
point I think that was sort of the the
talk was that you when you went to
dinner with them they were gonna nicely
let you go and it was just it turned out
just to be a lovely dinner but I was
nervous throughout the whole I can swear
in America know it so that one of the
cost favorite questions to Dan and David
surviving into tonight and they always
say yeah uses their agency so yeah they
always toyed with us made us suffer
Valar dohaeris
how grueling was it for you guys to film
all the battles that you had this year
would you remember the dream jihad it
was really cold and it went on for like
50 nights it was really cold we were all
in the middle of Northern Ireland
freezing in a place called - yeah it was
it was you know it was more I mean it
was in the dead of Northern Irish winter
I mean I know like here in New York you
you have him pretty harsh - but it was
also because of the time thing because
they were night shoots no it's it's like
being constantly jet lag
remember that dream the recurring dream
you had like this was 30 nights in a row
this must be this must be this must be
something in you or a fact it's really
cold I also imagine there is actually
snowing so like you're cold all of your
like extremities are cold but then on
top of that like the snow stops and then
suddenly someone shouts in the
background like get the fake snow in and
then someone just bothers you we've all
this chemical snow just me yeah bit of
rest by you like awesome I think that's
like a lot of it was like that because
that you get you just get like a little
wind and you like and then it's like
everything stuff it's up again I just
need to go on holiday yeah I want to
know what Harmons recurring dream
seriously also who else this shocked
that gray worms survived yeah 100% me I
think when when I mean when characters
are making plans we're gonna settle down
after this we're gonna go we're having
on the beach it's gonna be you know it's
gonna be great yeah it's like it's like
the copies like retiring next week like
you're bad
I can't believe great worm is still
alive you guys have been sending in so
many amazing comments right now
Zion says terrible ending short sweet to
the point yeah better myself
random says the most exciting 90 minutes
on my screen in my 32 years of Earth I
love that we have mixed reaction I'm
this this episode I mean I was getting
reactions on Twitter comments on my
review last night it is genuine
divisive yeah I'm really genuinely happy
that people are out there enjoying it
yeah Rama was not enjoying it any of
this episode is so very disappointing I
mean all the hype this was so
underwhelming way to kill the night King
I I mean when I'm looking back to the
comment or to the theory that we
highlighted last week about thank you my
king flying to King's Landing not
actually being at the Battle of
Winterfell and creating a secondary army
of whites going against Cersei and
surprising her that would have been so
epic and we were so convinced that was
gonna happen and no a friend of mine was
pushing back against my take on Twitter
last night was saying it seems like it
seems like your your complaint is that
it didn't go down the way you wanted it
to okay I think that is kind of a fair
thing to say but we're not talking about
like you know far out ridiculous fans
were talking about fan service we're
talking about what would have been an
amazing we're talking about the the
clues and the plot of the entire series
paying off we and there was the reason
why I'm so mad that something like that
night King Theory or something like that
didn't happen is because it's better
than what did happen yeah it's more
surprising yeah there are the clues for
it were everywhere and then on top of
that it better fits with the themes of
the series that Cersei is the one who is
ignoring the greater threat she should
pay a price for that she shouldn't turn
out to be right exactly
terrible another theory from el Moussa
he said I think there will be another
night king in the future no one wonders
about where the babies were or where are
they the babies were turned into the
generals the babies from Craster well
yeah but there's more that's been going
on yeah for years and years
Craster giving the babies so so
presumably like the one that we saw
turned in season five right would still
probably be a baby I guess we are a
toddler no but they all got destroyed
when the necking gonna be another night
can mean a lot of people bring the
babies up yeah when the night King dies
everybody that he turned the night king
is an off switch yeah the entire army
yes so I don't think that's a thing yeah
AV nine two four eight so the night king
is basically like a
at a thousand-year-old God and can no
one shoot dragons from 100 meters gets
killed by a teacher yeah I think that
that's like really a fair criticism I
mean the night I mean the night King the
he acted dumb yeah it was a dumb obvious
trap and he fell for it hook line and
sinker and then a teenage girl granted a
badass teenage girl but a teenage girl
nonetheless snuck past their entire army
yep all of his generals and then jumped
onto his back and stabbed like that's
really how it I don't know if you guys
can tell but I'm not your comments are
absolutely crushing it right now though
Oh sin says only a fool fights against
Dothrak ease in an open field which I
guess is a Robert Baratheon quote my
king says hold my beer yeah the way that
the Dothraki went out was just
unbelievably stupid yeah I feel badly
for them what what what is the battle
strategy of sending all of your cards
brave against the entire army before you
have a visual on them and not supporting
them what did they think was like that
was the catalyst for the rest of the
episode right Danny took off because she
was so upset she couldn't stick to the
plan anymore because she was upset about
what happened to the girl she had told
us what the plan was supposed to be
though what did they I just don't
understand what the I think was going to
happen yeah they sent that othe rocky in
one big charge and everybody just sat
there watching those lights go out no
strategy there Ally says or ail Ally
what about the symbols what about the
symbols you are so right I read that I
was obviously on reddit yeah night
because I couldn't sleep there I I read
that there was a featurette or an
interview or something where where David
and Dan or maybe Bryan cogman said that
the symbols that the White Walkers
create like their art or whatever is
essentially a corruption of these
symbolism used by the children of the
forest so it's essentially them dunking
on the children of the forest and just
kind of being dicks and I guess there's
like everything else there's nothing
more to it than that we get the most
shallow possible surface reading of
all of the lore that's been built up for
two decades and that's it like I want
answers on that stuff too and we're just
not going to get it let's see if you can
answer Nathan's question Newton says can
someone explain the vision that Millis
Andre and Aria both had before REO took
off the vision that they yeah I didn't
see a vision but are we referring to the
fact that she had told her in the past
that she would kill people with many
different colored eyes well they were in
that room right room were they dragged
right back died the Hound was in there I
guess there was that shot where they
were all looking into the fire is that
one what did Mel say - she said what are
they what do we say to the god of death
yeah serious bro callback this honestly
was a moment that that made me so happy
yes I was a moment I was like yes I was
definitely pleased with that moment I
need to read watch it because yeah if
they were I'm seeing in my head now and
if they were staring at the fire they
yeah they might have seen something yeah
take a look at what Robert said cuz
you're gonna have a lot of thoughts
about that so Aria is azor Ahai that
would be awesome I don't I don't know
and and at this point is it the princess
that was promised
yeah and that's that's didn't miss Andi
had that line where she it was a
mistranslation essentially that the noun
was actually gender-neutral and could be
prince or princess and you know there's
been so much speculation and I think it
is very Game of Thrones for you know a
prophecy to never actually have one
objective solution or payoff right that
fits with the theory with the series
overall I just to me I think it's
something that the show is never going
to bring up or address ever again like
Eric and Mel and they're dead like who's
left like the Hound isn't the Hound you
know he sees visions or whatever but
he's talking about he's not gonna bring
it up let's talk about that
fYI dancer gave a really great comment
said what about the night king and bran
staredown weird a brand go when he
phased out for a few like let's talk
about the fact that while the whole
battle was going on brands like BRB
gonna go warg into a murder of crows I'm
gonna go I'm just gonna go what I mean
what did you what did he do he just was
watching I mean waiting for the last
thing bran did was help Arya and Sansa
kid little finger yes which was great
yes and I've been waiting ever since for
him to do anything else yeah and he just
sits there and also hasn't he just
hasn't done anything yeah my theory is
that he went to go watch endgame like he
was like this episode sucks I'm gonna go
I'm gonna go see The Avengers do
something cool because this is boy it
was a big weekend for the Starks man
um let's rapid fire through all the
months I don't want you guys to think
that we completely hated this episode
just a lot of the parts but I still
loved Game of Thrones as a whole I'm
just so conflicted right now because now
we have three episodes left the night
King storyline is completely wrapped up
and it almost seems like a lot of things
wound up not mattering you're not gonna
get a payoff and quite a bit I have I
have some bullet point notes here no
Mike I want to start with things that
wound up not mattering and will never be
paid off in the show first of all we
touched on this a little bit but
Melisandre's entire story the prince
that was promised azor Ahai a light
bringer the sword heard season long
vacation to volantis or wherever like
what was she what was she doing there
what was the point why did she leave
only to reappear Winterfell at the right
moment I mean she she lit the fire great
she told re to go stab tonight King re I
couldn't figure that out on our own yeah
okay it seemed like she was pointless um
John I hate this one so John revealing
his identity to Danny at the end of the
last episode why did they put it there
if it was never going to have any effect
on the events of this episode yeah it
felt like this would have been there
were so many opportunities in this
episode for John to have like a hero
moment like a Targaryen moment to
finally you know step into his true
identity and at the same time proved to
Danny like she would see it right like
when she's burning the night king with
Dragon Fire imagine John walks into the
fire and kills the night king there it
would mirror Danny's survival of Khal
Drogo's funeral pyre
yeah in the first season and it would be
to her it would be proof that he is
Aegon Targaryen yeah it would have been
an amazing moment that paid off
something from seven seasons ago so of
course they couldn't do it I'm gonna
interject right now for his ghost yeah
where's ghost where he's going
I mean I have I have this in my list
where where's go student so mad right
now we got him for a brief second battle
and battle and we never saw him again
are you kidding me
first of all why was he not by John's
side why would you send him out with the
Dothraki why wasn't he next to Edie who
he knows from the Nights Watch
I wasn't he fighting why wasn't he with
it imagine the crypts why imagine John
is is is facing down undead Viserion and
instead of just standing there
slack-jawed and getting lucky that
already happened I can get that move in
ghost comes in distracts of serían long
enough for John to stab him with a
balloon and then at least give ghost a
good death gift or something to do give
John something to do besides just was
gonna go off into the forest and go get
9 Iria and her pack and come in and be a
nice little Calvary it would've been
really far fetched but I would have
liked him but that would be pay off I'm
really upset I I said this last night
but I'm trying to imagine a decade ago
when I was reading the books for the
first time if a time travel time
traveler from this terrible dark future
had had come up to me and whispered in
my ear the direwolves don't matter
actually I would have called him a liar
yeah it seems impossible that's
something that was so important in the
books such an integral part of the story
has just been completely sidelined
because of CG budget yeah or whatever
it's it's beyond infuriating give me
your last few points yeah yeah how about
the I mean we talked about the White
Walkers but how about the fact that they
didn't even fight anyone in this episode
like the White Walkers themselves there
was no fighting they just walked through
they just had slow-motion walks that
I've seen turned into some very good
gifts they were kind of rare they never
fought it wasn't no there was no battles
with the White Walkers I mean I just
we've we've been going but I will stop
yes we've been ranting you guys have
been sending us some amazing comments
and if right now there's one more
comment tonight that I want to read
right says they showed how are you could
get past the White Walkers in the
library
yes Arya is sneaky she's very
were dumb zombies I was not white
walkers those were whites yes they're
different yes I was bummed that that
scene that we were waiting to see from
the trailer of Aria looking so panicked
of Aria having her whole identity shaken
was just running from these whites and
it wasn't
Rickon come back to life it wasn't
someone that she knew and loved chasing
after her because that would have been
really amazing it was just her using her
amazing skills creeping around a library
right but doing that doesn't prove that
she can walk like literally the night
king is in the godswood his generals are
arrayed around them yeah and she just
flipped through that doesn't those
things are not equal to me yeah I agree
but we're gonna end it right here let's
cut it off before I yeah thank you all
so much for submitting your comments and
for tuning in today and be sure to join
us for theories and Thrones every Monday
morning at 8 a.m. west coast 11 a.m.
east coast for the next three episodes
three more and it'll be over and I think
I'll be relieved at that point we're
gonna be breaking down every episode
we're always gonna include your comments
your thoughts and your theories yes and
you can always tweet us your thoughts
anytime you'd like we will respond thank
you guys so much for watching theories
and Thrones and Mike and I will see you
next time maybe we'll have nicer things
to say hopefully five right
[Music]
you